c'étaient les idoles de leur adolescence
depuis cinq ans une tournée permet à des
chanteurs des années 60 à 80 de
retrouver le parfum du succès auprès de
leurs fans pour fêter les 5 ans d'âge
tendre et tête de bois une croisière en
méditerranée d'organiser marie béret
aurier et laurent beaufils sont
embarqués avec curiosité une croisière
de carte postale
quelque part entre malte et la sicile un
voyage idyllique mais m
et ils ne sont pas venus pour ça sur le
pont supérieur ce qui les intéresse
c'est leur idole de toujours
franck alamo et rajeuni dessus sur le
bateau allait 3e et 4000 personnes qui
sont enfermés avec 40 artistes
alors là il ya que trois formes un
trader
ils sont sûrs de nous tomber dessus car
la vie à bord c'est ça faire la bise à
dany boy la photo avec georgette lemaire
ou mieux un plateau repas aux côtés de
bobby solo bordelais
on peut les approcher plus facilement et
c'est vrai que l'on pousse aussi gentils
les uns les autres
vous voyez ces idoles les approcher et
pour le même prix environ 1000 euros la
semaine
les écouter chanter
chaque soir
cinq chanteurs font le plat dans deux
concerts comme cette fois là isabelle
aubret et hervé vilard
on a caché casser nos petits cochons
pour venir ici donc c'est très bien
nos économies sont partis on s'est amusé
c'est tout ce qui compte
et pour ceux qui on n'aurait pas assez
les concerts il y en a même dans la
journée
oui
ce jour là en plein après midi claude
barzotti provoque une émeute
c'est la preuve qu'il n'ya pas d'artiste
au ringard que le public
il aime peut-être bien le rap mais les
noms si ses souvenirs il aime bien celle
à il est bien évident il m
en france on aime les artistes
populaires et oui c'est la niche et le
tort les rênes de la croisière et les
fans
elles n'ont jamais ainsi jouer serré
dans le noir jmg vous aimez tellement
magnifique michel aulas la gym je vous
ai suivi à montargis j'en ai rêvé de riz
en photo avec